Tina is in Milwaukee Wisconsin hi Tina
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
good afternoon Dave thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up so my husband and I are
kind of at a disagreement right now we
currently say 15% of our income towards
retirement well we have about $30,000
that auto loans and he wants to get
those paid off but in order to do that
we have to stop contributing for the
next two years to our retirement
accounts
what's your household income one hundred
and fifteen thousand years so why does
it take two years to pay off thirty
thousand dollars it's only fifteen
thousand a year well I mean we won all
of our we have all of our bills between
the mortgage taxes you have those dad's
your other debt we do not okay let me
try this again do the math with me here
okay a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars minus thirty you should be able
to do that in one year okay you see how
I'm seeing doing that I mean I'm not
looking I'm looking at the details of
your budget but what I'm challenging is
your standard of living sure your level
of commitment to sacrifice deep enough
to get this done I don't think it takes
two years to pay off thirty thousand
dollars and in fact I know it doesn't
millions of people paid it off faster so
you're just beginning to fool with this
idea you guys are just starting some of
these discussions and somewhere along
the line I entered the picture and I'm
starting to become the financial piece
course ten years ago okay you flunked
okay I suppose if you want to say that
there's no way you graduate from that
class at F $30,000 in card that we paid
off $70,000 worth of other debt between
school loans and credit cards meanwhile
you borrow 30 grand on two cars correct
yeah you flunked we were pretty clear
never
again I mean that's the only way to get
out of debt stop borrowing so yeah so
the the formula is this
it's an emotional formula because it's a
behavior based situation the the angrier
you are at the situation or the more
motivated you are at the situation
whether it's anger or fear the deeper
you will sacrifice the deeper you
sacrifice the faster you get out of debt
the faster you get out of debt the
faster you don't have any payments and
you now have that money to build wealth
the shortest distance between where you
are and wealthy is debt-free because it
clears up all the money you're spending
on these other stuff that's what you
learned or should learn in the class so
angry and that that's so what I'm saying
is if I'm in your shoes I'm not gonna
just kind of wander out of that I'm
gonna get a little more fired up I'm
gonna do it in one year and yes of
course you know we teach you to
temporarily stop investing while you pay
off debts correct that's what we teach
yes that is correct
okay and so who's not one to do that you
were hit with you what you you know me
I'm a free spirit of the group okay it's
not a free spirit thing really on that
it's um it's a it's a you know free
spirit just means I'm not as nerdy and
I'm not as detail-oriented and that kind
of stuff it doesn't mean that because I
see it as if we're ready contributing
15% for retirement funds and we have a
net worth of 360,000 were 35 years old
mm-hmm what's a little car debt is how I
look at it no you know what's a little
backache not a big deal it's just um you
know what's a cigarette every now and
then it doesn't kill you completely it
just makes you sick you know I mean you
do whatever you want to do but that's
that's the same logic pattern you're
following the critical thinking is bad I
mean you can you can tolerate a lot of
stuff but the question is just what's
going to get you to where you want to go
faster they live like no one else so
later you can live and give like no one
else is what I would do I didn't even
say to sell the cars I just said let's
just roll up our sleeves and let's get
serious about this and clean this mess
up
and then let's get back into saving 15%
of our income to see if you had followed
what you were supposed to have learned
you would never $350,000 net worth now
you'd probably have a million dollar net
worth it's probably cost you that much
in the decade while you've been screwing
around with this stuff so that that's
the problem is the data points all tell
us the shortest way to wealth the
wealthy people avoid consumer debt of
any kind and that gives them the control
of their most powerful wealth building
tool which is their income and you just
got to decide if you're gonna do that or
not we can be friends and you not do my
stuff I got lots of friends that don't
do my stuff but if you want to do you
call me on the radio so if you want to
do our stuff that's what we teach and
the reason we teach it is it has its the
shortest distance between where you are
and wealth and we want you to be wealthy
so you can change your family tree and
so you can be outrageously generous
every day millionaires